hey this is presh chillwalker sports
betting has evolved from an activity of
the few in just certain locations to
being mainstream in many sports leagues
even if you were just browsing the news
you might come across betting odds
what exactly do these numbers mean
this video is neither to encourage nor
discourage sports betting but rather to
understand the numbers and the
mathematics behind them to be an
informed citizen
I'm going to go over three of the most
common ways that sports betting odds are
represented
let's start out with moneyline or
American odds
here's an example of a money line
Chicago Plus 150.
this means you place a bet of 100 for a
profit of one hundred and fifty dollars
if Chicago wins if Chicago loses you
lose your 100 bet
is this a good Gamble
mathematically we can calculate the
implied probability that Chicago wins
this will be 100 divided by 150 plus 100
which equals 40 percent
if there's a higher than 40 percent
chance of Chicago winning the game this
would be a profitable Gamble and if
there is a less than 40 percent chance
this would not be a profitable Gamble
moneyline can also be expressed as a
negative number like New York minus 120.
this means New York is a favorite to win
the match
this means you need to bet 120 dollars
for a profit of just one hundred dollars
if New York wins the game
again we can calculate the implied
probability that New York would win the
game and this will be 120 divided by 120
plus 100 which equals approximately 54.5
percent
odds can also be expressed in fractional
form like Chicago six slash four
this means you need to bet four dollars
for a profit of six dollars if Chicago
wins
we can also convert this to an implied
probability as four divided by four plus
six and this is equal to 40 percent
so again if you think Chicago has more
than a 40 chance of winning the game
this would be a profitable bet and if
you think Chicago has less than a 40
chance of winning the game it would not
be a profitable Gamble
odds can also be expressed in decimal
form like 2.5
you can think about decimal odds as a
multiplier
for every one dollar you bet you'll get
a total payout of 2.5 dollars if Chicago
wins we can also convert this to an
implied probability and this is just one
divided by 2.5 which equals 40 percent
so we now have different ways of
expressing exactly the same implied
probability
money line odds of plus 150 are
equivalent to fractional odds of six
over four are equivalent to decimal odds
of 2.5 are equivalent to an implied
probability of 40 percent that's
mathematically at least we're not going
into the details of how the bets are
taken and actually whether they pay out
the whole amount
in fact sports betting lines often have
an advantage built into them
so how might the sportsbooks have an
edge let's take an example of a match
between team a and Team B
let's say teammate a win has a money
line of Plus 200.
team beta win has a money line of
negative 250. let's calculate the
implied probability of each team winning
so team a will be about 33.3 percent and
Team B will be 71.4 percent
approximately
now if you add up these implied
probabilities you'll get a number that
is larger than 100 percent now if you
had money line odds that were exactly
Fair gambles and only one team could win
the two probabilities would have to add
up to 100 so you could see there's an
edge that's baked into these lines so
you want to be careful about strictly
relying on only the numbers there's a
lot of psychology and other factors that
go into sports betting
but now just to return to the
mathematics let's suppose we have a
general implied probability of P let's
write some general formulas if the money
line is plus M the formula is 100
divided by M plus 100
. for fractional odds of w b you want B
divided by B plus W
for decimal odds D you just take 1
divided by the decimal odds now if the
money line is a negative number negative
n you take n divided by n Plus 100.
so why exactly are these formulas true
I'm going to give a justification
let's start out with a money line bet of
Plus 150.
so in one case you could win and if you
did win you would win 150 profit
you could also lose and then you would
be out your bet of 100 so this will be
minus one hundred
let's say your probability of winning is
p so that'll be the probability of the
upper branch that means your probability
of losing is one minus P that's the
lower branch
so to calculate the expected value we
take P multiplied by 150 so it'll be
150p then we take 1 minus P multiplied
by negative 100 we add this so this will
be minus 100 multiplied by 1 minus p
for this to be a fair gamble the
expected value of the game has to be
equal to zero
so we can now solve this equation for p
we have 150p minus 100 plus 100 p is
equal to zero so 250p is equal to 100 or
p is equal to 0.4 which equals 40
percent
now what if the money line was a general
positive number like plus m
so if you win you get a profit of M if
you lose you lose one hundred dollars so
we again put the probability of winning
and losing here we can calculate the
expected value by taking P multiplied by
m then we take 1 minus P multiplied by
negative 100 we add these together the
expected value has to be equal to zero
so we now just solve this equation for p
and we get the general formula p is
equal to 100 divided by M plus 100. what
if the money line was a negative number
like negative n when you win you get a
profit of 100 and when you lose you lose
your bet of n so that's negative n
we can again now do the expected value
calculation here so we have 100 P minus
n multiplied by 1 minus P this all has
to be equal to zero
we solve this equation for p and we end
up with the formula that P is equal to n
divided by n Plus 100.
now let's do fractional odds let's say
you have six over four so if you win you
get a profit of six if you lose you lose
four dollars so again we'll go ahead and
do this expected value calculation we
have 6p minus 4 multiplied by 1 minus P
this needs to be equal to zero so we can
go ahead and calculate p and we get that
P is equal to 0.4 or 40 percent
now what about decimal odds like 2.5
this is one thing we have to be a little
bit careful about if you win you win 2.5
but you have to subtract your bet of one
so your profit is 1.5
so we put 1.5 in this Branch you lose
your bet which will be -1
. so we now go ahead and do this
expected value calculation so we have
1.5 P minus a 1 minus p
this equals 0. so we just solved this
equation for p and we see It'll be p is
equal to 0.4 or 40 percent
so sports betting has become part of our
mainstream culture and it's good to
understand these numbers and the
mathematics behind them
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time